では よろしくお願いします
今日はとてもまあまあ難しい話になる可能性はありますけど
で まあわからないところはわからないままで置いておいても構いません
まあ肝心なこの仏教でいう輪廻転生って何なのかと
まあそれはそれなりに信じたり信じなかったりすることがありまして
現代ですね まあそれはあまり信じないのは
まあヨーロッパではそんなに輪廻やらね
まあ信じてないということになりまして
その影響で日本でもまあそんなのは嘘やというふうに言っていることはありますけど
昔の日本ではそうは思っていなかったんです
で 仏教の知識ですから
まあそれはその通りでしょうというふうにはまあ信じてはいたんです
まあそういうことで 周りに似てどういうものになるかということで話してみますと思います
で まずは輪廻転生に対する反論で
できるだけ全部書いてありますので
お読みになるだけで十分だと思いますけど
まで説明するところはございません
で まずヨーロッパとかね
そこら辺での教えで見られるのは
この死後は天国か地獄へ行くように決まっていると
あの 一神教というかね
一神教になると だいたいその話になるんですね
まあヒンドゥー教も一神教ですけど
一応 でも輪廻っていうものは考えているんです
ヒンドゥー教以外の一神教は
地獄と天国しかないんだと
だから転生なんかはもってのほか
ありえないと言ってますね
で しかし この地獄と天国があるんだということは
そんなに宗教の大発見ではなくて
まあ人間が原始的な時代からなんとなく信じていた概念なんですよ
それはもう あの 何といいますか
まあ形式的な宗教も受け継いだだけの話で
そこで私の反論は青い色で書いてありまして
これを信じる人々も中間的な存在
パーゲタリーというものを考える羽目になったんですと
で これがキリスト教でも後でできた概念で
もう本当に人間が一発で天国か地獄に決められるかとということになりまして
例えば洗礼を受けてキリスト教になるのに
ろくにいいことをやっていないんだと
懺悔はしていないんだと
悪いことばっかりしているんだと
しかし その人と全く神を否定している人々と一緒に永遠の地獄に落としていいのかと
最低神様ぐらい信じているのではないかということを考えちゃって
だからといっていきなり天国に行かせちゃうと
本当に神様を信じて道徳を守って懺悔をしている人々と一色でなるんだから
なんかちょっと なんて言いますかね
ちょっと割に合わないんですね
例えば 真剣真面目に神様を信じて道徳を守っている敬虔な人と
まるっきり無関心で 小さい時は洗礼を受けたんですけど
まあ好き勝手に生きている人と死んだらみんないっぺんに天国というと
なんかちょっと割り合わないんだわ
割に合わないんではないかということで
まあちょっと一時的に苦しむ場所があるんだと
罪を滅す場所があるんだという考え方もできちゃったんですね
結局は輪廻否定しようと
輪廻というか 再生を否定しようとしながら否定できなくなるんですね
そういうのは矛盾になります
それから この生命は死で終わりという考え方もありますね
それは一般的な考え方で
生命は死んだらそれで終わりでしょうと
でもそれも信仰ですよ
別にどうやって証拠を出すんですかね
死んだ それで全て灰になったと
それも科学的な実証をしているわけじゃなくて
ただ現代人の自分の気持ち
気分で喋ってるだけなんです
だから天国があるということと同じ
まあ実証してないんです
それよく覚えておいてください
その 2つも天国があるんだぞと言ったっても
どうったことはないんです
ただ 昔 原始時代から人間が信じていた考え方で
では現代人がそんなのありません
知って言ってるんですかね
知って言ってるわけじゃないんです
死んだら人間みんな終わりやと
それもあれと同じ もう単なる信仰で観念であんまり当てにならないんですよ
はい 次に行きます 反論の続き
命心は細胞の働きで動きかな
働きで死で細胞が壊れてすべて終わり
で という考え方があります
まあ全部細胞の働きではないかと
しかし そんな結論づくのはちょっと早いんじゃないかと私は思いますよ
なぜかというと 心の研究は全く進んでいないんです
ただ 体の肉体の研究はほとんどできてますけど
心ってどうやって働くかって
これはもう全然まだまだもう全然やってないんです
なんとなくもうただ脳細胞だけで生きてるんではないんだと
脳も体も結構感情やら心の影響を受けているんではないかと
それは分かってますよ
人間がご飯だけで生きてるんじゃなくて
やっぱり明るい気持ちでいると結構元気になるし
体は で 暗い気持ちでいると体も壊れていくし
ということは 人間の気持ち
感情が体もそれなりに支配しているんだということは一応わかっている
科学的な世界でも しかし
その働きでどういうふうなものかということは
全然研究はしていないんです
だから こんな研究もしていないのに結論だけ出してくるなよっていうことが私の思考なんです
で それから転生というなら
それは子または孫などの子孫としてであって
この転生はないと これがよく日本で私が聞いた話なんです
自分の生まれ変わりはもう子供やと思ってるんですね
だからこの先祖崇拝とか
そういうことから出ているんです
しかし 子や孫や自分だと勘違いしている
それは何のこともない
自分の子供が自分だと勘違いしているだけ
自分の孫は自分だと勘違いしている
いい加減な勘違いなんです
子供も孫もそう思ってないんですよ
子供に聞いてみてください
お前を父親の分身ですか？と
父親の生まれ変わりですかと
ものすごい反発すると思いますよ
だから 私個人にしたっても
父親の生まれ変わりやと言っちゃうと気持ち悪いでしょうに
おじいさんの生まれ変わりやと
それはありえないんです
これは日本の文化的に先祖崇拝という習慣がありまして
その習慣もはっきり理解しないで
ごちゃごちゃ何か言うだけの話なんです
決してこのもう 調べて研究する必要あるテーマではありません
ただの井戸端で喋っているような感じで
もう何のこともない話なんです
はい で 次に反論はよくわからない
そんなこと言っても仏教でも禅でも
っていうのは それに私の反論は
まあそういえばその通りですと
これがよくわからない
それに私もあまり異論は立ちません
で 次のポイントは輪廻を信じることになるでしょう
この信じるというのはちょっと色を変えたんですけど
もう仏教の場合 仏教に対する反論なんで
結局あなた方もそれを信じているでしょうに
でも迷信なんかは嫌ですと
それにもあまり私は反論しません
それもその通りですよ
ただ 仏教の世界でも輪廻を信じている人々がいますけど
まあ大体は信仰ですよ
別に証拠を探して もうもう成立して証明出して
だから輪廻やということを言っているわけじゃない
まあただ ほとんどの場合は信じているんですね
信仰っていうのは もうちょっと危うく危ないものなんですよ
たとえ輪廻であろうとも
信仰はそんなにありがたいものじゃないんです
人を馬鹿にしちゃうんですよ
だから その反論はまあ一応あるんです
信じるだけの概念は良くない
しかし このように言っている人を叩けば
心から信じているというべき
いろいろ誇りがいくらでも出てくるのではないでしょうか
ということを私 また反論なんです
なんかややこしくて 文章は私にしても何書いてるかわからない
これはこういう まあまあ
ただの冗談的な反論ですけど
私は信仰は嫌やと 迷信は嫌やと言っている人々いるでしょ
いろいろ調べてください
調べてくると 信じているものはいくらでも出てくるんですよ
あれが信じる これが信じるとか
いくらでもあります 試しにどなたか
もう私は何一つも信じませんという人を出させてみてください
いろいろ疑問や質問を出したところであれこれやと
いろんなものを信じているんですよ
人間というのは だからあんまり出しゃばったことを言わない方がいいんです
特に現代生きてる我々は何一つも証拠のないものは信じませんよとすごく傲慢な態度で言っても
実際は人間そんなもんじゃないんですよ
かなりのものを信じているんです
くだらないいろんなものを
まあ最低占いぐらいでも信じてるでしょうに
方角はなんせやとかね
あれは結構効きますよとかね
風水占いは見事に当たりますよとか
何の中あれもあれも信仰でしょうに
何の科学的な証拠もないでしょうに
だから人間っていうのはいろんなことを信じているんです
だから輪廻は信仰になるんだから信じませんと言ったっても
まあ大したことではありません
しかし 信仰は良くないということを私たちは言ってます
それは仏教は厳密に言うんです
何一つもこの迷信的なものは信じるなよと
だから本当の仏教徒であるならば
もう占いでも何でも信じてはいけないんです
信じてないんだからといって
大胆で馬鹿にして批判したりするんではなくて
まあ証拠ないし だからわからないし
放っておきましょうと
私の人生にはそんなに関係ありませんと
占ってもらってももらわなくたっても
自分が頑張ればうまくいくんじゃないかと
そういう感じで仏教徒の生き方はするんですよ
だからといって 仏教の国々で迷信なんかないんでしょうかという
とんでもないんですよ
くだらない迷信 いくらでもあります
あれほどお釈迦様が反対しているのに
こんな これはもう人間のやり方なんですよ
何か信じた方がなんかみんな気分がいいみたいんですね
で 日本の子供たちはサンタさん信じてるような感じで
もうアホで腐ったれの無意味な話やとわかっているにも関わらず信じていると
まあなんとなく気分がいいんですよ
それだけのこと はい 次に
輪廻転生はそんなに必要ですか？と
我々にとってそんなに必要な概念ですかね
それが なぜ証拠もないのに
輪廻や転生などのことを考えたり
信じたりするのですか？という
いわゆるプラクティカリティという
この何か役に立ちますか
そんな考え方 それを考えてみましょう
はい それでなぜ輪廻なんかということで
ポイントだけさっと並べてみます
なんで人間 因縁なんかはね
くだらないことを考えなくてもいいのに考えるかというと
まず死にたくないのに死ぬでしょ
昔から 死にたくないんですよ
しかし 死んじゃうんですよ
だからこれがもう納得いかないんですね
悔しいんです その悔しさで
遠い昔からの原始時代からの人間が死んでから何かなるんだぞとは思っているんです
それで悔しさが紛らわせるんですよ
死にたくないのに死ぬということ
いわゆる死を認めたくないんですね
人間っていうのは 死んだという言葉さえも使わない
他界しましたと 天国に召されましたという言葉さえもくだらない言葉使っているんです
それ２番目はもっと長く生きてみたかった
それは上と同じく感じますけど
意味は違うんです 人間も
例えばよく元気で楽しく
何の問題もなく生きていると
なんか足らなくなるんですよ
特に年になってくると
もっと若くいたいんだと思うんです
年取ってもう腰も足も何でももう痛くなって
体が動かなくなっちゃって嫌やと
若い人々を見ると羨ましくてたまらなくなっちゃうんですね
ということで いくらか幸せで生きている人にしても
生きたことで十分満足していないんですよ
もっと生きたい もっと楽しみたい
もっと遊びたいという不満感があるんです
生きることにすべて これでもっと食べたいのに死んじゃうし
もっと遊びたいのに死んじゃうし
もっと家族と仲良くしたいのに
もう自分がもう出て行っちゃうし
それで心にはすごく不安が出てくるんですね
それでどなたかが大丈夫です
死んでも天国あるんだからとか何とか言うと
もうすごくその考え方にしがみつくんです
ああ そう 天国でみんなまたみんな一緒になりますからとか
そういうごく一般的によくみんな思ってるんですよ
家族もみんな 奥さんも旦那もみんな天国でまた一緒になるんだと
でもそれまた考えると笑われちゃいますよ
まあ夫婦はすごく仲が良くて
一人が先に亡くなったところで寂しくてたまらないと
その人にとっては天国に一緒になることはありがたい話ですけど
互いに憎しみ合っていたならばどうしますかね
こいつを早く死んでくれないかと
思っていて 早く死んだところで
やっと楽になりましたというケースもいくらでもありますよ
そこで死んだところでまた一緒になると
まあちょっと面白くないと思いますよ
あるいは離婚してしまったならばどうなるんですかね
天国で家族は 天国でも離婚あるんですかね
だからあんなのは人間のあまりにもおかしい思考なんです
単なる長生きしたかっただけの話なんです
いわゆる生きることに不満があっただけの話なんです
次のポイントは 亡くなった親しい人のことを忘れられない
この死に別れっていうのは
今よりも昔は激しくあったんです
かなり人間っていうのはもう戦争好きでしょ
人間というのは人殺すことさえできれば
これほどありがたいことはないと思っているんです
だから人殺しはヒーローにするんですよ
ヒーロー 英雄 それぐらい人殺し好きなんです
ヒーローというのはみんな人殺しでしょ
だから今ちょっと危なくて
いろんな国際的な法律やらいろいろできているんだから
みんなこのあまり戦争に行こうとはしないんです
だからそんなに人殺しは見当たりませんだけど
昔はもうとったもののものやと
なんだかんで 昔ったってそんな遠い昔じゃないんですよ
ヨーロッパがいくらか文化的になっても
ほんの百年二百年もないでしょうに
そこまではもう殺しては自分のものにする
殺しては自分のものにする
アラビア人もそうでしょうし
アラビア人には知識 学問は結構発達したものありましたけど
ものすごいものがありましたし
これイスラム教が出てきたところで
一気に成りもう野蛮的なものになってしまったんです
アラビア人の文化っていうのは結構進んでいたんです
まあエジプトやらね まあもう結構文化でしょう
知識的には で まあそこがいきなりなくなって
新しい宗教が現れてきて
これが殺す宗教なんですね
殺してもう奪って進んでいく
だから現代社会ではそれほど見られませんだけど
昔はまあもう旦那は殺されるわ
子供たち殺されるわ もう切りがないんですね
今もね ないわけないでしょうに
イラクに行ってみたら
もう子供たちももうゴキブリみたいに殺されるわ
イラク戦争ばっかり表に出して
その陰でもうパレスチナとイラク
イスラエル人がね ものすごい激しく殺し合いやってるわ
だからこの残された人々の気持ちを考えると
どれほど悲しいかと 子供たち殺されちゃう
その親はどんな気分になるんでしょうかね
ただパチパチパチと撃って
もうなんとかして殺される
だから この  そういうこと
昔から激しくありましたから
人間にはもう生きていられないんですよ
もう生活できないんですよ
残された両親に自分の子供はみんな殺されちゃうと
もう生きていられないんですよ
その悲しいことで それでやっと慰めになるのは
まあ死後が何か天国でもありますよと
言うと それでなんとなく
あの我慢できない強烈な悲しみがなんとかなるんです
そこでまあ そんなに平和な社会にしたっても
随分親しい人が亡くなっちゃうと
まあ子供とかね そんなもので
親とかね まあ天国に行きましたということで
自分の心の痛みをなんとかごまかすんです
そういう考え方でも転生のことを考えちゃうんです
だからなくてはならない概念になっているんです
死んだらそれでハイやと言っちゃうと
例えばあの世田谷区でしたっけね
子供はみんな家族を殺されたでしょうね
それでも残されたおじい様とかいるでしょうね
まあ大丈夫 まあもうもうはいですからね
気にしないでくださいと言うと
それで問題解決するんでしょうかね
いまだに犯人見つけてないし
だからこの我慢できない
この悲しみ 生きていられない
この悲しみ 悩みをなんとかもう暗示的な思考ででももう解決しようとしているんですよ
だから人間にはどうしても必要な概念になっているんです
次に今の幸福なくなる不安はない
これよくあります 突然
私にも日本の方々はね
なんか分からないんだけど
結構あの 恐怖感があるんだと言われる時あるんですよ
それで何に怖いんですか？何が恐怖ですか？と聞くと
それはわからない もうそれはわからないんだけど
なんかすごく怖くなるんだと
それ 私は聞くのは冗談で聞いてるんです
知ってます それは今の自分の安定した生き方がもしかすると壊れたらどうしようかと
年金でも入らなくなったらどうしようかと
寝たきりにでもなったらどうしようかと
ボケたらどうしようかと
というすっごい不安なんです
それが自分で知らないんですね
もう知るとさらに怖くなるんだから
知ろうともしない 抑えるんです
抑えてもそれは恐怖感として出てくるんです
そういう人も落ち着いてもらうためには
まあ大丈夫 何かなって死んだっても天国なんかあるんだからと言っちゃって言ってあげればもう大丈夫です
あなた様に往生できますからとか何とか言うと
ああそうですかと あまりこの結束言う必要ないんですよ
ただなんとなく言っちゃえば信じるんです
こういうことで こういうことで言っちゃうと信じません
論理的に言うと ただ言えばいいんです
すぐ信じる 人間心そんなもんですよ
もう信仰はやめと言うんですけど
信仰だったらありがたいと思ってるんです
その方が楽で考えるよりは
で 次にあるのは この今世の不平不満がなくなるでしょう
逆に不幸な人の場合は
いろんな不平不満を持ってるでしょう
ああ こんなのは死んでからなくなりますと
まあ成仏できますから
もうなんとか言葉を使う
成仏か天国か極楽どうか
もうなんとか言葉を使って来世のことを考える
そうするといくらか納得できる
今ダメでも将来はそうではありませんと
来世はそうではありませんと
なんで日本の人々はいきなり突然自殺するのかと
それなんです いろんな社会的な不平不満に出会ったところで
不正的なことに出会ったところで簡単に自殺する
これでもう自分が救われたと思うんです
もし死んだら それできれいさっぱり終わりですよと言っちゃうと自殺しないんです
あんた損するだけですと
あるいは日本の社会は死んだ人々っていうのはまるっきり無関心で忘れてしまうんだったら
誰も自殺しようと思わないんです
それどんな犯罪者でも死んじゃうとみんな手弱く
おがむんだから これ便利な考え方で
みんな軽々と自殺して責任逃れる
悪いことしたら自分で責任持たなくちゃあかんのに
もう自殺しちゃえば全部済むと思ってるんです
だからそういう それは日本だけのことで
他の国々でも同じことなんですね
他の国々でも生きてる不平不満は生まれ変わりがあるんだからということで
解説し 解決しようとするんです
地獄なんかあったら 嫌な人のことも我慢できるでしょ
自分では悔しくて嫌でもものすごく手強い
もう嫌な人々がいる 悪いことばっかりするわ
でも自分には反論も攻撃も何もできない
自分が弱い 地獄あるんだぞと教えてあげれば我慢できる
ああ そうか あいつは地獄に落ちるんだから大丈夫やと
今はそんなことしたってもということで
まあ気分がいいんです
で 次にこの自分がいるという実感が虚偽です
それはちょっとこれは大事なポイントで
私たちには自分がいるんだぞという実感があるんですね
これ すごい虚偽なんですよ
だから自分がもうきれいさっぱり消えるんだよということは思ってないんです
本当のとこを言うと この人間
死んだら全部終わりますよと言ってる人々も
あれ 正直に言ってるわけじゃないんですよ
だからたたけばいいんで
ちょっといろんな反論で
疑問で 自我が強いんですよ
自我が強い人が決して死後で全て終わると思わないんです
終わってほしくないんです
はい 次のポイントに行きます
行動に責任を感じることもなく
気楽に生きられるでしょう
これはまあ 輪廻の反対する概念なんですけど
これタイトルは変わってないんで
で これは反対の意見で輪廻がない場合っていう人々の場合はね
責任 自分の行動に責任を感じることなく
気楽に生きていられる
輪廻否定すると まあ楽しく生きていればそれだけの人生でしょうと
それから罪を犯しても逃げ切れれば勝ち
輪廻がない場合は だから輪廻がないと言っている人々は
そういう目的で言ってるんです
良心をキスを気にする人だけ真面目に生きていればいい
輪廻なんかありません
だから罪を犯したっても逃げ切ればいいよと
バレなきゃいいんじゃないかと
楽に生きていれば それ道徳なんか労心に悩んでいる人だったら守ればいいんじゃないんですかね
俺には関係ないんだぞという態度なんです
で 良心を気にしない人が増えると
世界は危険 しかし この世の中で良心なんかない人間が出てくるとどうなるんですかね
大変なことになるんです
良心がないと 人々っていうのはどこまで悪いことをするかわからないんですよ
だから それはあまりいいことではありません
良心があっても 他人によって簡単に壊されます
また 良心我々を持っていても
人々がそれ簡単に壊せますよ
例えばアメリカ人というのはすごく良心のある人々なんですよ
もう正義やらあれやこれやとか言いふらしてますけどね
あまりこの他人の国を占領することやら攻撃することは好きじゃないんです
一般人は しかし その良心どうなったんですかね
2  3人の人々の考え方で
これも出来上がった でっち上げた嘘を言いふらしちゃって
全国民がやっぱり戦争するべきだとすぐ決めたでしょうに
だからテロ事件が起きたのは
もうアルカイダという人々だそうですけど
何人でしたっけ？このサウジアラビア人でしょうね
だったらサウジアラビアに爆弾を落とせばいいのに
何の関係もないイラクに爆弾を落とすと
だから見事に良心を崩れちゃったんです
姿勢がなくなるんですよ
だから私たちにも良心があったりしたっても
簡単に壊れちゃうんです
それが だから道徳は守れないんです
はい そこで輪廻否定すると
これからこの仏教的な立場で説明します
輪廻なんか否定しちゃうと
輪廻とか転生なんか否定しちゃうと
この 倫理道徳などは確定できません
口大きい声で言えなくなるんですよ
嘘を言うなよとかね 人を殺すなよとかね
盗むなよとか 言えなくなっちゃうんですよ
嫌なやつを殺しても何が悪いんですかと
自分にものがないんだから
人から盗ったっても何が悪いんですかと
なんで私は物なしで貧乏でいなくちゃいけないんですかと
だから ある人々から全部取ってやるぞということもできるんですよ
だから道徳っていうのは確定できなくなるんです
で 生きることは娯楽に限る
だから生きるってことは何なのかというと
娯楽を楽しむことだと
これもあまり美しい人生論ではないんですよ
実際にこの世の中で娯楽しか能がない人々はいるんですよ
その人々も結局は人生が虚しくて
何のために生きるかさっぱりわからなくて
結局どんどんエスカレートしていくの
娯楽感覚がね あれもこれも欲しい欲しいと走りっぱなしで苦しんで死ぬだけで
決して美しい生き方ではありません
で 弱者は気の毒 倫理がなければ気の毒でしょ
一回でしか一回しか人生がないんだから
これまた弱者で生まれて
かわいそうでどうにもならんね
そこで生命の際に説明はない
なんで一人一人の生命が互いに違いますかと
なんで二人の同じ人間
二人がいないんですかと
この世の中で この説明はできなくなるんです
ペンにおいておきます
次に この献身貢献より先に我が身ということになるんです
この世の中で みんな我が身だけかわいくて献身しましょう
貢献しましょうとか そんなのはもう後回しではなくて
もう出てこなくなっちゃうんです
だから決して世界は良くなるわけじゃないんですよ
否定することで だから何かよくよく見ると
もうみんな信じてるんです
転生があるんだと 信じてない人っていうのはもうほとんどいない
あまりにも極端的な強烈な哲学者かとか
誰かいるかもしれませんだけどね
これはもう 1,000万人のうち一人しかいないんです
何だかんだ言っても どこかで信じてるんです
だから世の中で献身などはね
貢献などとすごく美しいことだと
道徳は守るべきだと みんなもうなんとなく言ってるんです
なんとなく言ってるんだから
あまり力強くないんです
この言い方は だから言っても言っても破るばっかしなんですけど
善行と言ったっても 結局わが道しか考えてないでしょうに
イラク人解放するんじゃなくて
石油奪ってるだけの話でしょうに
だから結局は自分の利益しか考えてないんですけど
やっぱりそれでも建前だけでも言っちゃうんですよ
建前だけでも言わないと成り立たなくなりますね
ということは どこかで信じているんだということなんです
はい それからこの反対側の意見
人が死んだら絶対生まれ変わると
これも今まで仏教の意見言ってるわけでもないんです
たまたま私の意見を出すだけで
この世論を言ってるんです
人にはこの不滅な魂がある
全くも壊れない インディストラクチブル
全くも壊れない魂がある
だから死んだっても それ壊れませんでしょうと
塵は塵に戻るが 神は これ 2番目の意見
神は人にスピリット 霊というものは注入したから確実に死後があると
そういうふうな考え方もあります
世の中体を見ると これは塵は塵に帰ますよと
でも人間の場合は何か注入されているんですね
スピリットというもの
だからそれが亡くなりませんと
次に 生命をもとも一切の現象は大本である真我が回転して現れている
故に現象世界は幻覚です
生死と関係なく 我がこの幻覚を見破っ
見破らない限り流転する
これは日本ではあまり馴染みないんですけどね
その考え方は これは結構立派な思考ですよ
これはヒンドゥー教の思考で
上はもういくらかというと
上の 2つは西洋的な思考で
馬鹿にでもわかる  3番目はヒンドゥーの宗教で
結構もう行動な物事を考え方
行動に考えないとわからないです
だからヒンドゥー教で言っているのは
このもともと真我がありましたと
実体というものは現象でない
いわゆるノーメンとして
ありましたと それが分かれて分離して
現象世界 フェノメナル世界というものは現れましたと
しかし この今我々に見えている現象世界のは真我の回転なんです
だから家がある 木がある
私がいるということは幻覚です
そんなのはない それは単なる現象
幻覚で だから私たちは現象にしがみついているだけで
実際はたった一つの我ですと
全部 だから個人個人がこの幻覚を破らない限りは
もう幻想から現象へと
現象から現象へと変わっていくんだそうというヒンドゥー教の輪廻の話
難しいんだから次に行きましょう
しかし 仏教は輪廻転生に反発する
今までの輪廻転生には結局仏教は反発する
ただ みんなほとんどの人間がなんとなく信じている輪廻転生っていうのは
もう下らんと 正しくないんだと
で 仏教の反発されます
不滅たる魂はこの世に何をしに来たのですか？と
私たちには不滅の魂があるんだったら
何やってるんですかね
この世に生まれて 来たこと自体も馬鹿馬鹿らしいでしょうに
こんな酷い世界に苦労しなくちゃ生きていられない世界に
厳しく勉強して試験合格しなかったら仕事もない世界に
真面目に仕事をしたっても簡単にクビになる世界に何で生まれたんですかね
魂っていうのは馬鹿じゃないんですかね
だからもう何の意味もない話ですと
それが あるいは魂は浄化するために来たんですか？あるいは向上するために来たんですか？堕落するために来たんですかね
あるいは魂が戯れるために来たんですかね
この世の中に それはいとしい反論があるんです
浄化するために来たんだというと
浄化などは可能なら魂は簡単に変化するでしょう
そうするとインディストラクチブルというこの不滅の魂でなくなっちゃうんです
言う人がいるんですよ
魂が浄化するためにこの世の中で現れたんだと
いうと 魂が頑張って浄化しよう
魂が変化するでしょうに
そうすると魂でなくなっちゃうんです
魂は変わらないもののはずなんです
だからそれなんかくだらない矛盾の話なんです
それで向上も同じことで
魂には向上ありえないんです
変化しないものだから
堕落すると堕落もありえないんでしょうに
変化しないんだから それで戯れるために来たと思ったら
くだらないところに来たもんですよ
魂は この世の中で何一ついいことないのに
別なところに行けばよかったのに
だからそんなのはもう
もうなんかもう何言ってるのかという話です
そこをですぎ 魂は変化しないなら
道徳倫理は無意味です
もし私たちの魂はまるっきり影響を受けないというならば
人を殺しても人を生かしてあげても意味がないんです
実際 インドでこの六師外道という人がいたんです
その人々は この頑固とヒンドゥ教のバラモン教には反対したんです
バラモン教は一生懸命この動物を生贄にして
もう 8匹とかね  200匹とか
神様を機嫌取っておきなさいよと
そうすると魂が死後は神様のところに行くんだそうと言って金儲けてたんで
商売していたんです それであの大金持ちの人々と王家の人々だけ宗教儀式やるんです
一般人にはできない 牛と神にあげちゃうと
それでもう生きていられませんだから
あのクリスマスツリーにいろんなものぶら下がってるでしょ
あれは何なのかご存知ですか？昔は神様に生贄をして
それは生贄をなんとか木に付けてあったんだそうです
その習慣です だから まあ自分たちの命を助けてくれてるね
動物とかね もう神様のためやと思って平気で殺しちゃうと
やっぱり貧しい人々には生きていられない
それであなた方は神に生贄もしてないんだから
天国に行けるわけないんだというと
これあまりにも差別でしょ
金持ちだけ天国に行けるという
とんでもない話なんです
それでこの六師外道という人々は
ではざまあみろというところで
徹底的に論理的に喋り出しちゃったんです
魂は切っても切れませんと
潰しても潰せませんと
死にませんと言ったところ
だからね こんな 8匹の動物とかね
あるいは 1ヶ月間の生贄
儀式 供養とかやってもね
何の意味もないんだよ
魂は変わらない だから
あるいはあっちこっち行ってごちゃごちゃごちゃごちゃ人を殺しちゃっても
何の罪にもなりません
魂は変わりませんだから
ということで もう無茶道徳なんかは否定しちゃったんです
しかし 論理は成り立ってます
もしも不滅の不変化の個体的な
絶対壊れない魂があるとするならば
罪を犯しても善行為したっても
魂は知ったものじゃないんで
それは そういうことで彼らが道徳を批判したんですよね
しかし 仏教では外道外道と呼ぶんですけど
その人々もそれなりにインド人がかなり搾取されていたんだから
差別されていたんだから
なんとか攻撃でもしてやろうということで頑張ったことなんです
だから信者さんはいっぱいいたんですよ
信者さんはいっぱいいたんです
でもすべてあんまりにも成り立たない話でしょうし
だから壊れてしまったし
ヒンドゥー教はもう金持ちでしたから
王様たちでしたから まあ後援者たちはね
もう抑えてしまったんで
全部 それからなんで偉大なる絶対的なものを具体的に知ることはできないのですか？そんなにもすごい魂があるんだったら
なんで知らんですかね
それは 例えばヒンドゥー教でもウパニシャッドという哲学宗派がありまして
そこで瞑想で ヨーガで魂を体験するっていう話があるんです
で 日本でもヨーガは人気あるし
ヨーガの本来の意味は
この真我を体験することなんです
脂肪を減らすことではありません
今はただ単に脂肪を減らすだけのためにやってますけどね
で そこですごい難しい修行して苦行してやっとわかるぐらい隠れてるんですね
魂が 偉大なる魂は これおかしいんですよ
偉大なるものっていうのは
一番表で出てきて見えるはずなんです
それに長部経典である経典がありまして
この魂っていうのはもうないというある唯物論者がずっと研究した研究を記録しているんですよ
あまり今日は引用しませんですけど
もう彼のポイントも そんなにすごい魂があるんだったらすぐわかるでしょうと言って人殺してみたんです
王子でしたから 人殺す権利があるんです
だからこの犯罪者 誰かが見つけたら
彼が人としたことは このそのまま傷跡何一つもしないで
ただ息を止めさせて人殺しちゃうんです
殺して死んだのかと 口と鼻をね
強引に力ある人々はもうしまっておけばもう死にますからね
死んだ瞬間で手を離してくださいと
で じっと見ているので
魂が出ていくのかと 出ていかないんですね
それでその王子がやっぱりこんなの嘘やと
自分の実験で結果が出なかったんだから
もう一つの研究は この血一滴も出ることなく
まだ人を殺す で 殺す前に人を測ってみる
測ってみて すぐに殺す
殺してから遺体を測ってみる
それで彼が考えたのは
生きている時は魂がある
死んじゃったら魂が出ていく
これ 目では見えないみたい
魂は透明でとか だったら重さがあるでしょうし
で 測ってみたんです 測ってみたら何のことない
生きている時よりは死んだ時は重さが重いんです
遺体は 王様びっくり 何やこれと
魂が出ていくんじゃなくて
何か変なもの入ったんではないかと
そういう実験いくつかありまして
彼は否定するんです でも
彼があんなことを残酷なことをやった
なぜやったかというと
この魂が偉大なるもので
不滅不変化しないものだと思っていただからなんです
だったらはっきりわかるはずでしょうし
たくさん実験やったみたいです
はい それで魂の存在は証明できないのに
まあ専権的に信じている
これも人間が専権的に信じている概念だけであって
証明はないんです あれも前に言った
なんで人間が考えるんですか？という理由なんですよ
死にたくないとか 書いたでしょ
同じ理由なんです それそれから転生を推測する
先験的に魂があるんだと勝手なことを言ってから転生するんだよと推測するだけ
変わらぬ魂は自分の過去を知るはずが
我々は何も覚えていない
絶対的な魂が転生するんだったら
すべて覚えているはずでしょうに
何も覚えていないでしょう
普遍的な実体の移転として考える転生概念は
経験的な智慧ではなく
信仰的な推測に過ぎないのです
魂が死んでからどこかに行きますよということは経験ではありません
単なる信仰 信仰から出てきた推測なんですね
そんなことで これは仏教の反論
人類が信じている転生に仏教はすごく反論するんです
はい 次に行きます しかし
仏教は輪廻転生 まあ同じこと
転生の考えは 絶対的な不滅の魂の移転として
輪廻をする主体しか考えてないですのです
そこでこの世の中で転生転生という人々は何考えているか
この魂の移転 絶対的な不滅の実体は本当にあるのかと調べてないのです
だから転生するんだそうと言う前に
魂があるのかと調べてほしいんですよ
だから仏教はケチつけてるんです
あんた方 全然証拠も何もない
先験的な概念から始めているでしょう
だからすべて壊れますよ
土台は 一切の宗教哲学は証明してない概念の上に成り立っているんだから
これやばいと まずこの土台が本当かないかと調べましょうよ
魂があるかないか調べましょうよというのはブッダの立場なんです
まず生命 生きること 世界などは何なのかとありのままに探求するべきです
まず我々は生きるということはどういうものかと探求してみましょうと
転生なんかはそれから観察する課題なのです
生きるということは何なのかとわかってから
本当に転生なんかあるのかと
それから考えればいいんですよ
別に だから順番間違ってます
仏教から見れば 我々は転生あるないか困らなくてもいいんです
まず私が何者かと調べることを先なんです
私に魂があるのかと すべて発見してから転生があるのかと考えても良いんです
お釈迦様その順番です